I know. I know. Get
close.
feel.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in
and we mentioned before many times this
book is essentially
a summary of Sunnah.
But it's its own book in its own right
because it has
a lot of the opinions of
in his books
and and other works of the sort. it
also adds the
of to the four.
But this book is not geared which is why
we've chosen this book is not geared
towards mentioning the various med
that's not the subject of this book. The
subject of this book is
the sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam.
And in that respect it is largely taken
from
by
and as
mentioned in
his introduction that the subject of the
book is not
the of the
of Islam with respect to the various
rulings of Islam.
The subject matter is whatever was
narrated of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam sunnah. Now remember we've
mentioned this many times. What is the
difference? Isn't the med exactly the
sunnah? Aren't all the scholars and all
of the four imams attempting to
capture the sunnah? Yeah, sure. But
books built on a medb this follows a
very specific set of guidelines and is a
very specific type of book. We've
mentioned this many times before and
inshallah we'll mention it many times to
continue and that is that most of the
differences of opinions amongst the
mahib is not a difference of yes and no
a difference of halal and haram. It is a
difference of what is w and what is what
is mak and what is haram what is good
and what is better what is bad and what
is worse that is a very different
science altogether
for our intents and purposes as muslim
we
are attempting to follow the messenger
of Allah Sai wasallam with as little
differentiating
between those kinds of details. In this
particular class, we want to learn how
did he make woo, how did he make salah,
how did he give zakah, what should a
person do to fast, how did the
companions fast, etc.
And most of these topics or actually all
of them for instance they are agreed
upon amongst the scholars of Islam. As
we've mentioned before the majority of
the majority of
is agreed upon amongst the scholars of
Islam. The only difference is what is in
what the details the categorization
largely categorization
I'll give a couple of examples for
instance
all of the scholars agree all of them
all of the
including the
and all of them agree
that is sujud of forgetfulness.
It is
permissible
regardless of the mistake made in prayer
and valid to be done before salam and
after salam. They all agree on this.
What do they differ on?
When is it better to do it? before salam
and in what instances is it better to do
it after salam. This is the difference.
Another example,
all of the scholars of Islam agree all
of them that when a person stands to
make salah,
the person is to make
to recite
and then to recite in the obligatory
prayers
something else of the Quran after. All
of them agree on this. All of them. The
difference is what in some
that is
fat a pillar of salah
or is it preferable?
If you do not recite fat, is your salah
valid or not? That's the difference.
However, the
sunnah no, they all agree that this
is how the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam prayed that's how he prayed
that's how he made wudoo this is how he
prayed this is how he fasted this is how
he made the difference is in what
categorization largely in categorization
largely in details there is maybe 5%
of the rest and remaining of
Islamic jurisputants
that the madib
differ on with respect to
this is part of the sunnah or this is
not this is correct or this is
incorrect. There is that but it's very
very very small amount especially
contrasted with the rest of
that is what we are studying here
otherwise we're just not going to be
able to learn
because if a person wants to study
for instance
a particular med
and they want to understand why do these
med differ
that is not something that you can
acquire in one year or two years. This
is not even something that you can
reasonably acquire in five or 10 years.
This means a person needs to dedicate
himself to the discipline of a
particular medb and then expand on that
same med and then learn the other medib
and then continue to climb in
the differences of opinions until
they arrive back and understand the
reasonings behind these differences of
opinion. That is a whole different topic
altogether.
Alto together that is a different topic.
And this is why in any serious
discipline, not just in Islamic
sciences, but in any serious discipline,
you cannot Google answers. You cannot
just take you know bullet points and
learn a discipline. It does not work
that way. It doesn't work that way. It
doesn't work in the way of I want to
understand
why
aerospace
engineers differ on this particular
issue. This is not something that could
been answered very quickly. And you
might say why why not? Because many
disciplines have to be learned before we
can even understand the premise of these
differences of opinions. And this is why
people who jump the gun and leap into
the deep end of the pool end up drowning
themselves very often. And the problem
with this kind of drowning is you don't
even think that you're drowning. You
think that you're learning. So when a
person wishes to learn a particular
topic there is I as a Muslim want to
know how my prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam taught us to worship Allah
that's more or less clear very clear
right but then there is I want to learn
how this particular field of a science
of Islam how it's built and why it is
structured the way it is and how the
scholars of that particular field dealt
with particular issues that is a whole
other
we say we're I'm from kit and
kaboodleoodle that's a whole different
kettle of fish there that is very
different if you wanted to learn to read
books on physics and you don't know
mathematics is that going to work out no
it will not work out if you want to
learn engineering you want to read books
on engineering but you don't know
calculus and you don't know is this
going to work out. No. Engineering is
more trigonometry and geometry. If
you want to learn physics and you don't
know anything about calculus, is that
going to work out? No. You have to have
particular sciences that you've studied
before and even in in order to even be
able to understand the difference of
opinion because I'll give you an
example.
If for instance
I were to have a question on a
particular topic
let's say on salah or let's say on zak
and then I go on the internet and I look
up the difference of opinion on this
particular topic. Now each scholar or
each side of a debate they're going to
present their arguments. Correct. Each
one is going to present his arguments.
Let's say there are two arguments.
You will read the first argument and be
convinced. It's a scholar argument.
Obviously, you're going to be convinced.
Then you will read the second argument
and now you will be convinced. You'll be
confused.
How how do you differentiate between
what evidences takes prior priority?
Right? Prioritizing evidences
just this alone
is an entire books have been written on
this topic alone. How do we prioritize
evidences? Which evidences take
precedence over others? Right?
These are things that a person has to
study and not study because they're
trying to reach a particular u a
particular answer or a particular
outcome. They have to study these things
unbiased.
So they're not looking for a particular
thing. They study it properly through
its proper channels and arrive at its
conclusions. And this is why
one of the most destructive things that
has happened to us knowledgewise and not
just for the Muslim and Islamic
knowledge but in general and
human knowledge is
the printing press. Yes, the printing
press. It was not a good thing. Many
people believe that this is a good
thing. It's usually
you know put put off on people as a good
thing, but it was a very two-edged
sword. It was originally designed for
propaganda purposes. We have a public
that is able to read. They are literate.
We're able to propagandize particular
ideas and mass. But this was never a
good idea. This was not a good idea
because in order to even know that
certain books existed or certain fields
of science sciences or knowledge
existed, you would have to have spent
time with the people of that knowledge
and learn through them. And when you are
ready to read such a book, you will know
about it and you will know to get it.
But now you can go on your phone,
type in
books on, you know, one, two, three. I
have a whole thing search come up for
you. If you have enough money, you can
order an entire library to fill up this
whole masid today. Today, right? Is that
a good thing? That's going into a
pharmacy and just starting to pop pills
just right and knowledge that is not
understood. the scholars of Islam have
mentioned is pointed the loaded
weapon at people when you have a
halfnowledge that you don't understand
but you think you understand it. It's
having a loaded gun pointed at
people that you're sure is unloaded but
is actually loaded, right? And you're
just running around putting it in
people's face,
right? This is nothing nothing good is
going to end with this. Nothing good is
going to end with this. And that is why
knowledge can never be separated from
its people. Ever. The book will it ever
replace the author? Never. Will the book
ever replace the scholar? Never. Never.
the most powerful AI on earth to ever be
made or ever will be made will never be
able to will pair in comparison to the
the
you know inherent need of having the
scholars and this is why a lot of the
differences of opinions most people they
do not understand them and people start
to even fight amongst each other. They
start to fight amongst each other. What
did
when the Muslim started to differ in
their recitations and fight with each
other over the different recitations?
All of the recitations were correct, but
people were learning different
recitations. They were not ready to
learn. What did he do? He wrote one copy
for every region.
No one is to put pen to paper of any
other wording of the Quran, not even in
private. And everyone who has any Quran
written even in his private library that
contradicts this mus is to burn it.
That's exactly what they did. And it
saved the Muslim. This is what the
companions did because
again it's handing out loaded
weapons, you know, just parking a truck
outside the masid and just handing out
loaded pistols to everybody as they walk
by, as they leave for.
Here you go. Right. And then people,
everyone is armed and nobody knows how
to use these things. This is very, very
dangerous.
If you went to your doctor and I'll end
with this and he said, "Oh my god, you
have cancer. We got to start treatment
immediately."
Would you say, "Yeah, but it's a
difference of opinion. Some some doctors
say that this is cancerous." And some
doctors say that this is not cancer.
This is actually just a sunburn. It's
not melanoma. Some some do it's a
difference of opinion. It is more
convenient for me
that it not be cancer.
It is very inconvenient for it to be
cancer for me. I have things to do and
so forth. So I'm going to go with the
opinion that it is just a sunburn
inshallah.
How would that work out? But the idea
that if I have a really strong good
intention that this will somehow
you know
this will somehow cancel out
something that is halfbaked. This is
dangerous and this is why she als says
four types of people will completely
collapse society. Four types of people
ford.
[Silence]
They said four types of people will mark
the destruction of a society.
A halfbaked
linguist
and a halfbaked
theologian
and a half or a halfbaked philosopher, a
halfbaked
and a halfbaked doctor.
those who haven't reached the end of
those sciences yet. The halfbaked
linguist will destroy people's language.
The halfbaked theologian will destroy
people's religions.
The halfbaked
jurist will destroy people's
f and worship and the halfbaked doctor
will destroy what's left of people's
bodies after that. And we live in the
era of halfbaked.
Tik Tok. You want something? Here's Tik
Tok. You want something? Here's
Facebook. You want some more? Here's
Instagram.
Amazing. These scholars would have never
imagined that a day would come when
dancing children on a phone screen would
compete with Bkari. But here we are.
Alhamdulillah.